I want to talk about your husband axe
for a second cuz he and I are very close
and yeah and let's not get anyway I'm
curious you have friends that's friends
and sign language yeah oh I didn't know
actually that's not this is Jean and
this is friends yeah that's true
yogurt this is berry
whatever you this is yogurt this is
yogurt oh I thought you put it up
towards your nose that's what I do with
yogurt that gets the probiotics right in
their cultures the I'm curious to see
mind you you have your share of sex
scenes on this show they're they're very
PG but does that to mind when you have a
sex scene no no no no my husband likes
every type of relationship on the planet
that has positive energy behind it so
like he likes seeing lovers he likes it
when I fall in love on screen in front
of him and oftentimes whether it's
r-rated stuff I've done or I'm kissing
GD if he's watching it by himself and
I'm in the kitchen I'll hear him go
honey gets off he's really a great
wingman what a lovely lovely a
philosophy to have